envie d'une pause détente pour le
calendrier 100 % evelinois je vous
propose de relâcher votre esprit et
votre corps au spa Calico de cincir
l'école c'est le plus grand espace
bien-être d'île-de-fance donc autant
vous dire que vous avez l'embarras du
choix à partir de 26 € vous pourrez
profiter des différents bains à 34° du
sauna et du hamam si vous préférez les
massages les soins ou autres rituels
faites une pause au spa à partir de 61
€. et pour les plus sportifs des cours
animés sont proposés toute l'année
aquabike aquagym aquaraaining il y en a
pour tous les goûts compte 150 € pour
une dizaine de séances et n'oubliez pas
Pierre de Coubertin disait un esprit
saint dans un corps sain alors n'hésitez
pas